noah so nice having you here in studio
this is my first time interviewing you
you have fans all over the world from
shitz creek i've heard so much about you
so this is exciting for me you are on
broadway
you have a new album coming out you're
going to be a dad soon how busy are you
right now really just trying to pack
everything into one year um if at all
possible yeah it's it's a lot but it's
all good stuff you know so it's uh it's
it's exciting this is such an exciting
time for you so let's start with the
album sure adjustments how is this name
uh kind of the perfect word to use to
describe your new music and this stage
in your life well i feel like in the in
the creative process the word
adjustments just keeps coming back and
you know when we're in the studio it's
like great yeah we'll make a few
adjustments and we'll go again and that
that idea throughout you know the
pandemic era which is you know when this
record was largely conceived of and and
recorded um
it just felt appropriate there were a
lot of shifts that were all
we've all been making whether that's
internally in our own landscapes and we
were just talking about how like
everyone was forced into their homes and
ring lights and virtual stuff in our
industry and and also you know some of
the larger societal shifts that that we
were all kind of undertaking there was a
massive presidential election there was
for me like i got married during the
pandemic that was a huge shift there
were all of these little sort of things
that were requiring this kind of
off-balance like how do we get it back
on and um
and i love the idea that you know
adjustments are are hopeful things
they're they're about improvement
they're about you know trying to move
forward addressing some of the things
that aren't working and trying to move
towards something that works a little
better i love that so when people are
listening to this album what do you hope
they take away from it
i hope they just sit with it and and
reflect on their own world i mean i
think you know music to me has always
been something that i get to kind of
like actually process what's going on
for me internally and
you know
some of the some of the louder elements
of my life i can kind of sit back with
music and go okay how do i how do i feel
about this so i hope people you know put
this record on and listen to it front
front to back on their record player or
in their car or out for a walk you know
it's i think it's a reflective uh
album there's a lot of long tunes
there's a lot of like kind of ideas and
things that move through it and yeah i
hope people just process it in their own
way are you excited for having to hear
this new music or do you get nervous
like it's kind of like your baby getting
out there i'm very excited i mean you
know i recorded this at the end of 2020
with my dear friend matt barber and an
incredible band and so anytime you make
a record you just want to put it out
like immediately uh because you don't
want to have to sit with it for too long
yeah yeah
but i'm i'm really excited i think this
is this is my favorite of the three
records that i've made and and uh yeah
i'm i'm really stoked to put it out
that's so cool
okay so you got married a couple of
years ago you're going to be a dad do
you feel like an adult now
or did you always feel like an adult
because i don't feel like i certainly
did not always feel like an adult i'm
i'm starting to
have to reckon with the fact that i'm i
i have more adult elements of my life
than i used to but uh but i don't know i
i wonder if i will
i wonder what what adjustments will will
be in my future i don't really know that
was good i like that uh okay so i asked
you about your nerves or excitement with
an album do you feel the same way when
it comes to becoming a dad are you
excited are you nervous what's like the
number one thing you're so excited about
i mean just to meet to meet the kid you
know i mean that's that's the most
exciting thing in the world right now to
me and and uh yeah i mean who knows
there's lots to be
nervous and scared about but i think you
know the best you can do is just kind of
trust yourself and trust your partner
and and yeah
amplify the excitement i like that do
you think you'll be good with diapers
i'm i'm ready
that was the right answer that was a
test when you passed
um you know when it comes to you know
music that you've made over the years
especially when it comes to this album
do you have musical influences artists
that you've looked up to or or just
different different sounds that have
influenced your style yeah i think so i
mean you know the the
the 70s obviously being the kind of the
era to me that singer songwriters people
who who wrote their own music from their
own perspective played it on their own
instruments um people like bob dylan
obviously i think is kind of the
greatest songwriter of all time and tom
waits being a a piano man and those are
artists who have who have reinvented
themselves a lot of different times too
and different sounds and different vocal
uh qualities um paul simon uh nina
simone leonard cohen
joni mitchell neil young the the list
kind of goes on and i feel like part of
the fun too of this of this you know
making music in this era is that there's
all of this kind of uh
explosion of electronic sound and this
like kind of strange
quality that you can achieve with these
sort of i you know i'm thankful for my
incredible band members bringing what
they do to it because i only play
instruments that make their own sound
like an acoustic guitar piano i don't
know how to turn knobs or plug things in
yeah yeah and uh and and i've i've just
got very lucky to play with some
incredible musicians who who just
elevated this soundscape so much that's
cool do you have a favorite song and
you're not supposed to have favorites
was there a single that stands out for
you
i mean they all it's cheesy to say but
they all have such a different place in
in my heart and mind i don't know i i
don't know that i could pick a favorite
honestly i think i honestly i think of
it as a as a collective cool yeah all
right let's talk broadway this is your
first time on broadway how is it going
yeah it's uh it's oh my god it's really
crazy it's really great to do
eight shows a week and we're in studio
54 which is a storied space yeah and uh
to be working on this play the minutes
tracy letts wrote it and is performing
in it and it's a steppenwolf
production and a lot of incredible
members of that ensemble it's just a
crazy thing to get to do uh
shit's creek coaster dan levy did he
show up opening night he did yeah what
was that like getting his support i mean
you know he's the best i'm not surprised
he's he's he's a just an incredibly uh
generous and thoughtful and wonderful
human being and and in a lot of ways he
helped me you know get to that point so
i think
for you know for all of us he thinks of
us as his children i'm sure
but it was really nice really nice to
see him and and yeah i mean that that
means the world that's awesome you know
people are wanting to know if there's
going to be more shit's creek a shit's
creek movie we've heard dan kind of say
a couple of comments are you on board
for this do you want this to happen i
want whatever is right to happen i i i
don't i don't know if if it's you know i
think a lot of things would have to go
right for that to be
you know the right thing but um i'm all
ears you know i i think getting together
with that group of people even for
dinner would be really right do you guys
get to do that or are you all so busy
now i mean you're incredibly busy like
do you guys get to still connect yeah i
mean
we definitely we're you know there's
there's it's like that kind of family
thing where you know you everyone's kind
of off doing their own thing and and we
still have that undercurrent of
connection and and uh yeah i mean i
probably see dan and annie the most but
uh but it's you know that that
connection doesn't go away i love that
uh well here at et canada we are
celebrating pride all month and you know
to have played such a beloved lgbtq plus
uh character that you know was just
adored by fans all over the world but
especially within that community what
does pride mean to you
oh i mean it's just it's an incredible
celebration i mean
i the one year that we got to do the the
pride parade the cast of shit's greek
got to march in the parade it was just
like
it was incredible i was so moved and so
excited to get to be a part of it it's
just like i don't know i love pride and
particularly in this city in toronto you
know we we we represent i love it um i
know you got married on lake huron yeah
is this your parents property yeah so
i'd like you to invite me next time okay
just throwing that out there to my next
wedding to your next wedding
to the next summer dinner party
i'll run it by my folks
you